[Musique]
la restauration exemplaire de la
madeleine de vézelay valu à son auteur
une commande bien plus considérable
celle de notre dame de paris
ce monument était devenu brusquement
célèbre grâce au roman de victor hugo
mais la faveur qu'il rencontre est
désormais dans le public rendait
d'autant plus inacceptables l'état de
délabrement dans lequel il se trouvait
il avait eu en effet à subir les
transformations abusive des chanoines du
xviiie siècle qui avait éventré sa
façade viollet-le-duc s'attela la tâche
qu'on lui confiait avec un zèle redoublé
quand on regarde notre dame de paris et
finalement quand on étudie toutes ces
restaurations
je crois que l'on est tous il faut
toujours être étonné par sa modestie via
des ducs a une réputation il ya un mythe
et on a toujours l'impression qu'il
transforme tout en fait je crois que
c'est tout à fait faux et quand on voit
effectivement ce qu'il a fait à vézelay
il a supprimé quelques travées gothique
à l'entrée la nef pour essayer de
rétablir la continuité romane bon je
crois qu'on ne lui reproche plus
vraiment maintenant il a à notre dame
effectivement rétabli une travée qui
avait pratiquement jamais exister à côté
du coeur n'est ce pas au coin du coeur
et de la nef le transept et de la nef
mais cela est finalement très peu de
choses par rapport si vous voulez à
d'autres transformations très brutale
qui avait lieu avant et qui auront lieu
après généralement pas par lui
[Musique]
à notre dame avant de commencer les
travaux
les ducs avec son ami la suce son
collaborateur l'astuce qui est mort du
récent cours de betterave ou avec une
déclaration tout à fait remarquable je
vais vous la cité mais exactement il
l'avait dit nous pensons que chaque
partie a ajouté à quelque époque ce soit
doivent en principe être conservés
consulter resterait dans le style qui
lui est propre
il ajoutait et cela avec une religieuse
discrétion avec une abnégation complète
de toutes opinions personnelles
une phrase admirable si véritablement
viollet-le-duc avait suivi une telle une
telle déclaration puis à personne
aujourd'hui une natte personnes le
critiquerai personnes l'attaquerait voix
et - encore - et vous pensez qu'il a
fait le contraire il a fait exactement
le contraire il a fait exactement le
contraire au nom du scientisme de son
siècle au nom de son scientisme propres
de son archéologie sme si je puis dire
il a refait ajouté il a surtout il a
surtout à la croisée du transept à
l'entrée de la nef à l'antre du coeur du
transept
il a reconstitué les ouvertures les les
petits oculi qui existait au visuel au
12e siècle et qui avait été supprimé 1
100 ans plus tard donc
il a voulu reconstituer un état qui
n'existait plus déjà depuis le moyen âge
c'est une erreur totale c'est une
horreur absolue l'extérieur il a
surchargé toutes les touts les
arcs-boutants toutes les culés des arcs
boutants tous les contreforts des arcs
boutants de petits édicules avait il
existe et on n'en sais absolument rien
il a au dessus de chacune des fenêtres
des chapelles il a ajouté des gable il a
ajouté des fleurons y ajouter les
contreforts il n'existait plus même s'il
avait existé
est il besoin de le refaire absolument
pas nous sommes du côté de la scène la
grande rose la très belle rose du
croisillon sud du transept
il a complètement le fait il a fait
pivoter de je sais plus combien de
degrés elle est plus que sept modèles
qu'elle était avant son passage alors
notre dame évidemment ne disons pas que
notre lame lui dois la vie
l'udc elle avait comme je vous le dis
toujours été toujours été entretenue
depuis depuis la révolution
mais notre lame existe mais ce n'a plus
notre dame tel qu'on l'avait vue telle
qu'elle avait existé
[Musique]
notre dame de paris le problème ne se
posait pas exactement comme
il se posait à vézelay n'est ce pas le
nierai pas les mêmes problème de
ceinture
il y avait un problème très grave un
enfant de paris s'était le problème de
l'iconographie qui avait presque
entièrement disparu
les statues avaient été brisées à la
résolution c'était une cathédrale ville
de toute sa substance iconographique
alors là je pense aujourd'hui dans ce
domaine particulier
je ne pense pas qu'on ait réellement
réaliser de progrès par rapport à
l'époque de dieu république parce que si
on se trouvait aujourd'hui devant le
même problème je ne vois pas comment on
pourrait le résoudre si ce n'est en ne
refusant pas la sculpture si on devait
refaire ce qui est civilisés que c'est à
dire de refaire une sculpture d'esprit
médiévale je pense que l'échec serait
aussi retentissant aujourd'hui qu'il a
été au 19e siècle alors on aurait le
choix entre dante et une sculpture
contemporaine inspirée ce qui serait
probablement très critiquée ou laisser
l'édifice dans les tomes se trouvaient
dans les taudis les ducs à trouver
c'est-à-dire privé de son iconographie
ce qui serait tout de même un petit peu
de marche
[Musique]